[Música]
tag
das
tartamuda
tres años
terapia
a veces como la nostalgia de pasar un
rato por la niñez me quedo pegada en
alguna de alguna m
para olvidarme de mis 23
a veces como la nostalgia de pasear un
rato por la niñez
lloro uno a veces no lloro
a veces me da miedo morirme
y como la nostalgia de pasear un rato
por la niñez dibujo pero ya no dibujo a
mi perrito oa mi mamá
dibujo la bolita con el palito de una
dibujo letras
que hacen versos que hacen las estrofas
que riman y son poemas
dibujo a mi mamá
describiendo el llanto de cuando el
cuerpo tartamudear
temblar
porque a veces esa nostalgia de pasar un
rato por mi niñez es el llanto del
primer baño después de nacer
y es que después de casi morir yo no
sobrevivir en así y yo era en el baño
anhelando la voz de mi mamá diciendo que
el agua lo lava todo
a veces tartamudeo con la lengua con el
cuerpo cuando el ataque de pánico es tan
fuerte que me regresa a los brazos de mi
mamá
a veces dibujos poemas a veces cuento
cuentos a veces
me inventa el cuenta en el que nunca fui
tartamudo
o nunca fui y paul a
a veces inclusive me voy a pasear por
una niñez que no fue la mía
23 años
ya no es tartamudo
a una terapia
escribe para dibujar
23 años
la poesía la salvó
aún tiembla
a un llama a su mamá
un juego de que maestra
pero ahora enseñar y más
entonces número uno soy poeta
número 2 soy sensible muy
desde que tengo uso de razón estoy en
escenarios recitando poemas bailando
actuando lo que sea menos cantando eso
sí no
y
mi exposición al arte ha sido siempre a
través de las artes escénicas y ha
tenido enamoramiento con varias
disciplinas pero me casé con la pasión
pues si yo pasamos juntas noches
tormentosas nos vamos en verano la playa
bailamos juntas con el 21 de diciembre
debo decir en definitiva que es el amor
lésbico más profundo que vivió
pero
pues si ello no nos enamoramos hasta que
pasamos la pubertad si yo sabía que
tenía un don de palabra coqueteamos un
par de veces pero el amor nació hasta
que salimos del cole
en el colegio
lo que aprendí de poesía es que hay que
dividir las sílabas existe doña sinalefa
y don alejandrino pero yo no sabía que
poesía va a las cárceles en talleres a
recordarles a reos que su corazón sigue
latiendo yo no sabía que poesía va a las
escuelas a escribir historias de colores
con niños y niñas no sabía que poesías
había terapia para personas con
trastornos mentales
a poesía me demostraron a mí a mi
generación ya todas sus generaciones
como hombres de otros países escribiendo
las mujeres entonces yo no tenía más que
hacer que le produzcan metáforas pasar
el examen
y seguir hasta que descubrí un día que
poesía no siempre animada
que no siempre estaba cargada de figuras
literarias con flores y ojos celestes
hasta que descubrí un día poesía en un
bar después del colegio
con una sangría y con un vestido que no
combinaba con sus trenes
con una risa suavecita y con fuertes
opiniones políticas ahí fue cuando me
enamoro
y le invite a salir
y después del primer beso primer verso
ya no hay vuelta atrás y yo como no soy
egoísta se la viene a presentar
inviten a salir por un café bailen y
escriban un verso con ella una línea
solo es
sobre el búsqueda pasando sobre el
mensaje buenos días de la tía sobre amor
o desamor
o sobre el mal día que están teniendo
con su pelo pero escribo en eso una
línea
escriban 2 luego 4 llegue de poesía
niños y niñas
conozcan
poesía es amorosa y pues si es honesta y
pues si es directa y configuró sin
figura igual de guapa
una vez hace un tiempo como de no hace
un tiempo yo
llegué a sentir que yo no era
suficientemente poeta porque nunca ha
publicado un libro entonces una vez
estaba en un evento y después de recitar
y todo sin hacer que una escritora
venezolana que se ha publicado libros y
me dice es que a mí no me interesa no
necesito saber si has publicado libros o
no
vos sos poeta porque hace sentir a la
gente entonces yo les digo a mí no me
interesa no necesito saber si su verso
tiene una consonante si siquiera saben
que es una metáfora si ustedes han
dejado
y van a dejar un sentimiento escrito ahí
está conocieron a mi esposa conocieron a
poesía gracias
[Aplausos]